Yeah,
well,
the today,
the two you just mentioned are two that
reasons I'm cooking really.
I mean,
uh,
Eliot Coleman as a farmer in the
northeastern part of Maine that I was
frustrated with this shortness of the
growing season.
And He,
um,
uh,
well he tells a story,
it's great storyteller,
but he tells a story about how he was
thinking of moving to France or to
Italy.
And he was looking at a map and he saw
that his farm is on the same latitude
as,
um,
northern Italy and southern France
provence.
And,
um,
he knew that,
uh,
there were vegetables,
that were,
uh,
daylight determined not temperature
determinant.
So if you could keep it above 32
degrees,
you could grow everything that you grow
in northern Italy and southern France in
the middle of the winter.
You could do that in me.
And as long as you can control the
temperature and not have it dip to 32
degrees.
So he invented these,
these,
these really revolutionary,
uh,
greenhouses,
so sort of hoop houses that prevented
ice crystallization and the planet and,
and got his farm going in ways that very
few people I've been able to do.
And now he's been mimicked all around
the world really.
Um,
so he was an inspiration for me because
in college when I was cooking for him on
this,
I was thinking,
you know,
Blue Hill farm was a great asset to,
it's,
it's 300 acres of pasture land and part
of the problem with farming and the
northeast of course,
is the weight.
What do you do from,
from December to May.
Uh,
and most of these farmers have other
jobs during this time and,
and,
and it's a very sort of,
uh,
a low revenue stream time.
So,
so what elliot invented,
or what Elliot took advantage of was
something that very few farmers had
thought about.
Uh,
and he did it by making money doing it,
which is the key.
So he was a huge influence in me and my
thinking that,
you know,
ultimately if I got good enough and,
and,
and could be,
uh,
Neil can make a career of cooking,
you know,
Blue Hill would be an asset for,
for a supply chain.
And then there's Joel Salitan who did
everything and I'm just talking about
really on the animal.
And it took advantage of this landscape
in ways that other farmers hadn't by,
um,
by raising different species of animals
in the same space.
And so both of these men informed me
greatly and then ultimately stone barns
great late because we've kind of
mimicked each of their operations at
stone barns,
made it our own for Westchester County,
but they're,
their basic philosophy,
uh,
is,
is all over the place.
It's humbling.
Well,
we have this 23,000
square foot greenhouse,
for example,
on the Elliot side,
right?
So,
uh,
that's Eliot Coleman writ large and
it's,
um,
and it's,
uh,
made for him.
It was built for,
uh,
you know,
based on,
on Westchester County,
which is to say,
uh,
that the taxes,
the,
the Labor that's a necessary for this
part of the country versus where Elliot
is.
So it needed to be quite a bit larger
than what Elliot does.
Uh,
but the underpinnings of what he wrote
so outright,
what he writes so eloquently about talks
about going about is,
is a strong soil,
uh,
and,
planting,
uh,
vegetables,
that,
uh,
take advantage of our natural,
um,
uh,
you know,
our natural ecology.
So for example,
you know,
we now,
I just harvested last week,
um,
we just harvested the farm,
just harvested,
um,
carrots from both the greenhouse and the
field,
and they're the best carrots of the
year.
And so what,
what people generally talk about the
northeast as I was saying before,
is,
you know,
it's,
it's dead during the winter,
right?
But in fact,
for certain vegetables like root
vegetables,
carrots,
and parsnips and Rutabaga and,
and,
and celery root,
um,
if you are willing to use hoop houses or
use something that,
that can prevent the temperature from
falling below 32 degrees,
you can actually have vegetables that
are better than any place in the country
because the starches through the coal,
through the freezing turn to sugars,
uh,
with these phrases.
So,
um,
you know,
we took a bricks test of this carrot.
Now I,
this particular card,
I went on the Internet and I found the
bricks test is,
uh,
the parts per billion of sugar in the,
in the vegetable,
right?
So we squeezed a little bit of carrot
juice on and took a reading and I looked
on the internet and they said the
highest reading for this type of care,
it was 14.6.
It took,
uh,
took,
thought of it and read it.
And it was 15.8
literally off the charts.
Right?
And so I was speaking to a plant
scientist who happens also to be a poet.
And I think he described it.
That's what's going on.
He said that when a vegetable gets
through a root vegetable or actually
other vegetables like Kale and Swiss
chard and uh,
and um,
uh,
Brussel sprouts,
but in this case and dead of winter when
these root vegetables and they're in the
ground,
feel the freeze coming,
they convert the starches to sugars to
try and raise their body temperature
about like making ice cream to vent ice
crystallization.
They're raising their body temperatures,
like the ice crystallization means
death.
So he said,
I think poetically,
uh,
you know,
what you're tasting is sweetness and
what the plant is telling you is I don't
want to die.
It's really interesting.
So it's taking advantage,
I mean this is sort of Elliot and Joel's
in any of these sustainable agriculture
minded individuals is taking advantage
of your natural ecology to produce
delicious and by definition,
healthful food.
That's a low impact on your environment.
So that's,
that's there.
And then on the,
on the animal side of things,
um,
one of the great benefits of being in
this New England areas,
grass is grassland.
So,
uh,
you know,
our goal and the goal of the farmers
that,
that practice,
the animal husbandry at stone barns is
to,
is to,
to take advantage to keep their eye on
the sunlight and have the sunlight feed
the grass and have the grasp of the
animals and the animals feed us,
you know,
so that the minimum amount of,
of grain inputs that we can take from
other farms outside of stone barns and
use what's in our own natural ecology.
It's what provides not only,
you know,
the most sustainable meats,
but also the most delicious because the,
the grass is this buffet of different
flavors and,
and nutrients and,
uh,
and it adds subtleties and the flavor of
the meat that you can't find elsewhere.
So those are two examples of many that
take advantage of our natural ecology
and,
uh,
and produced better tasting food.
Okay.